el cirujano realizará una cirugía
bariátrica si el esfuerzo por perder
peso mediante cambios en el estilo de
vida y medicamentos no ha sido exitoso
existen dos tipos de cirugía bariátrica
los procedimientos restrictivos
disminuyen el tamaño del estómago para
que la persona sienta saciedad
rápidamente después de la cirugía el
estómago tolera una taza de comida un
estómago normal tolera entre 4 y 6 tazas
los procedimientos malabsortivas
disminuyen la absorción de calorías en
el intestino delgado
antes de la cirugía se colocará una vía
intravenosa la cirugía bariátrica
requiere anestesia general la que lo
mantendrá dormido durante el
procedimiento
se insertará un tubo respiratorio por la
boca y en la tráquea para ayudarlo a
respirar durante la operación
el bypass gástrico conocido técnicamente
como bypass gástrico
es un procedimiento restrictivo y mal
absortiva ya que reduce el tamaño del
estómago y disminuye la absorción de
calorías en el intestino delgado
el cirujano utilizará uno de los dos
métodos de cirugía de bypass gástrico el
método abierto requiere una incisión de
entre 8 y 10 pulgadas 20 a 25
centímetros en el abdomen el método
laparoscópica sólo requiere varias
incisiones pequeñas y clave mediante las
cuales el cirujano pasará una paros
copio e instrumentos quirúrgicos un
laparoscopio es un instrumento delgado
con luz que proyecta imágenes de la
cirugía en un monitor en el quirófano
durante la cirugía de bypass gástrico
rubén y el cirujano utilizará grapas
quirúrgicas para crear un pequeño
compartimiento que funcionará como un
estómago nuevo esta bolsa tolerará una
taza de comida la parte inferior del
estómago continúa segregando jugos
digestivos pero no recibe alimento
luego el cirujano cortará el intestino
delgado bien lejos del estómago
levantará uno de los extremos libres y
lo unirá a la bolsa posteriormente unirá
el otro extremo libre inferior al
intestino delgado formando una
al pasar por alto la parte inferior del
estómago y la primera parte del
intestino delgado se absorberán menos
calorías cuando la comida atraviese este
nuevo camino las técnicas de bandas son
procedimientos restrictivos ayudan a
disminuir la ingesta de alimentos de dos
maneras encogiendo el estómago al tamaño
de una pequeña bolsa y creando una
abertura diminuta desde la bolsa al
resto del estómago
los alimentos pasan lentamente a través
de esta abertura estos factores harán
que sienta saciedad más rápidamente y
durante un tiempo más extenso en la
gastroplastia vertical con bandas
también conocida como bbg o grapado
estomacal
el cirujano abrirá una ventana en la
parte superior del estómago colocará
grapas en el estómago alrededor de la
ventana y hacia el esófago para crear
una pequeña bolsa en la parte superior
luego el cirujano pasará a una banda de
plástico rígido a través de la ventana
irá doblará alrededor del pequeño
orificio de salida de la bolsa lo que
evitará el estiramiento la comida pasará
desde esta bolsa a través de una
abertura diminuta a la parte inferior
del estómago y al resto del tracto
digestivo
durante una cirugía de banda gástrica
ajustable también conocida como hb o la
band el cirujano colocará una banda
inflable alrededor de la parte superior
del estómago como la banda es inflable
apretará el estómago para crear una
pequeña bolsa y una abertura estrecha
hacia la parte inferior más amplia
se puede realizar mediante incisiones
diminutas utilizando un laparoscopio la
banda se puede ajustar en cualquier
momento
la derivación biliopancreática es un
procedimiento malabsortivas que
disminuye la cantidad de calorías
absorbidas en el intestino delgado
el cirujano comenzará extrayendo parte
del estómago y dejando solo una pequeña
bolsa de atrás luego coser a el
intestino delgado a la bolsa
esto crea un camino directo desde la
bolsa al final del intestino delgado el
duodeno y el yeyuno son pasados por alto
en consecuencia se absorben pocas
calorías y nutrientes
para todos los métodos de cirugía
bariátrica
el cirujano cerrará las incisiones con
grapas o puntos después de la cirugía se
le retirará el tubo respiratorio y se lo
trasladará al área de recuperación para
controlarlo se le administrarán
medicamentos para el dolor y la dieta
avanzará gradualmente durante varios
días